one direction singer louis tomlinson's
sister felicity
dead at just 18. e.t learned that louis
was notified of his sister's death on
wednesday night
the singer and his family are said to be
devastated and louis has canceled his
upcoming promotional appearances
[Music]
felicity died of a suspected heart
attack
while rare in people as young as louie's
sister they're not unheard of
heart disease warning signs can start as
young as 18.
felicity was a successful influencer
with over a
million instagram followers last year
she revealed to fans that she was
planning to launch a fashion line under
her nickname
fizzy the metropolitan police service
tells et that police were called by
london
ambulance service on wednesday to a
residential address
following reports of a female in cardiac
arrest
they told et quote at this stage the
death is being treated as
unexplained a post-mortem examination
will take place
in due course earlier this week felicity
answered fan questions on her instagram
stories
including some about her close
relationship with louie
when one fan asked if she planned to get
any more tattoos
she revealed she was going to get her
brother's lyrics inked on her body
as for her favorite memory with louie
she wrote quote
recent ones our car rides home from x
factor auditions all giving opinions and
being so excited
seeing him excited the sad news comes
just a little
over two years after louie's mom joanna
died
she was diagnosed with an aggressive
form of leukemia in early 2016
leaving behind louis and his six
siblings
the 27 year old penned a heartbreaking
song about his mother's death
called two of us i will be the best
[Music]
during felicity's recent q a she
revealed that she was
deeply moved by her brother's new single
writing quote
i cried my eyes out in the back of my
uber but i
loved the song filled me with hope louis
opened up about his mother's death in
january 2017
during a sit-down with michael yo on
siriusxm's hits one
it's not really something that i feel
100 comfortable talking too much about
but just quickly um
yeah when i first found out about the
news i i kind of did want to throw the
towel in you know um
but it was my mum who said to me that i
just got to keep going she told me very
sternly that she wanted me to
following the news of his sister's death
fans took to twitter to offer their
condolences
and support in fact multiple hashtags
including
stay strong louis and hashtag pray for
tomlinson's began trending worldwide
james corden tweeted his love writing
you're not on your own in this at louis
tomlinson
so many people are pulling for you and
your family right now
charlie puth also tweeted his regrets
writing
prayers to louis tomlinson i can't
imagine how hard it is right now
love to you brother i'm so sorry we at
et want to send our love to louis and
his family during this tough time
too now of course this story is still
developing and we'll have
all the updates for you as they stream
in so be sure to subscribe to all things
et
in the meantime i'm hallie stevens bye
for now